[Music]
welcome to tucker carlson tonight we are
here at the presidential palace in
brasilia brazil a city famous to
architecture majors the world over a
completely planned city built in the
late 1950s as a new federal zone
in this sprawling country brazil
we're here because this is the home of
the president jr bolsonaro we just had
breakfast with him sat down with a
fascinating interview with him that went
on for more than an hour we'll have more
on that in a moment we're going to speak
to his son
but we're here in brazil broadcasting
all week for a reason if you're worried
about the future of the united states
this is a good place to come to get a
glimpse of it or what it might look like
depending on what choices we make
brazilian united states have much more
in common than we realize both are huge
countries brazil is actually larger than
the continental united states countries
with deep natural resources
diverse physical environment diverse
population and a very divided political
climate on one side you have a
nationalist party it's currently in
power now at least controls
the executive in brazil on the other
side you have in effect a globalist
party
and the tone of the politics here is
bitter and the stakes are very high
people go to prison in brazil routinely
when they lose elections
but the reason we're here is to take a
look specifically at what china is doing
in brazil all through latin america and
the caribbean and of course
all through africa
china has effectively become the
dominant colonial power
taking over countries mostly through
economic deals trade deals through the
presence of chinese companies and then
exploiting those countries for their
natural resources and effectively
controlling their political systems
brazil
is the last pro-american country of any
size in latin america but it's also the
last country resisting
china's colonial efforts and we thought
that would be worth watching considering
what's happening
in our country and our relationship with
china where's the biden administration
all of this well
the by administration has in effect done
nothing to protect brazil from
china's colonial interests and in fact
they've done a lot to help china by
weakening the relationship between the
u.s and brazil and by weakening
america's position in the world they've
done this quite aggressively you've
watched it you're living it
energy prices which are the key to any
economy have skyrocketed that's happened
on purpose this administration has done
that both with the sanctioned regimes
against russia and its emphasis on quote
green energy as a result of those two
factors you're seeing the biggest rise
in gas prices in american history and at
the same time you're seeing
a move
to
green energy forms that we buy from
china solar panels wind farms the
components for those come from china so
effectively you're seeing a transfer of
our energy grid from american control to
chinese control this is an attack on the
most basic institutions in american life
this is handing sovereignty over to our
main global rival
it's bad for america
in fact it's the worst possible thing
for america
so in a functioning democratic system
this would be a problem for the people
trying to do it you can't undermine the
country you lead and expect to continue
to lead it in a democracy
and the bite administration knows this
and that's one of the reasons
that the signature tactic of the bide
administration this is our topic tonight
has been the criminalizing of american
politics why have a political debate
when you can just arrest people who
disagree with you
and that has happened
far below the media radar
since the day joe biden was elected and
tonight to show it we want to go through
a litany a list
of americans who have been arrested
detained
by federal law enforcement on the orders
of the biden administration not because
they committed recognizable crimes but
because they disagreed with the
political aims of the bide
administration now again you're not
reading about this in the new york times
because the rest of the media are
pretending that it's not happening and
instead they're focused on the january
6th committee which has taken in fact a
lead role in this effort rounding up
enemies of the state
the entire process is a farce and that
was proved yesterday if you watched the
hearings yesterday you know how absurd
it is
democrats with the help of adam
kinzinger and liz chaney called up a
star witness who testified she heard
someone else say that donald trump
attacked a secret service agent and
tried to carjack the presidential
limousine
think about that the president united
states tried to seize control the
presidential limousine that he wasn't
driving it didn't make any sense
and then by the time that secret service
agents who were on the scene denied the
story to nbc news and other news outlets
nobody cared they weren't even
pretending that it was true
the initial story was the point the
shock value was the point not the
factual basis of it that's what passes
for rigorous investigation in congress
at the moment
but no media outlet is going to revisit
their decision to turn over their
airwaves to the january 6 committee even
after yesterday's debacle
it is in effect a show trial it is
absurd by definition and its absurdity
is the point the absurdity of it the
hollowness of it sends the message we
run the justice system now you are
powerless and that is the same message
that by administration has sent to
america for the last year and a half
with the help of merrick garland the
most political attorney general in
history
here's a list of the things they've done
because no one else has assembled it
here we go
january 27 2021 days after joe biden's
inauguration the justice department
arrests a man called douglas mackey
known online as ricky vaughn
you heard very little about this why
because douglas mackey had extremist
political views but under the american
system it doesn't matter if you have
unattractive or unpopular views your
views are protected by the first
amendment
he was arrested
for what a crime no for creating
internet memes that made fun of hillary
clinton but according to the justice
department those memes quote deprived
individuals of their constitutional
right to vote so he went to jail
then on february 3rd of the same year
2021 the fbi raids the homes of russell
taylor and alan hostetler what did they
do wrong
well they organized a lawful political
rally on january 6th they even had a
permit for the rally taylor also
committed the grave offense of being
seen with roger stone in the days before
january 6. that's now a crime too
not in a free country but in ours
then on april 28 2021 the fed sees the
cell phones and computers belonging to
the president's former lawyer rudy
giuliani that didn't used to be allowed
you can't seize the records of someone's
attorney
those are confidential lawyer client
communications
now at the time we were told that rudy
giuliani had done something illegal in
ukraine the walls were closing in
he was never charged with anything like
that
because it was all fake
but they got his privileged
communications anyway
then on june 24th 2021 the feds raided
the home of a giuliani associate called
george dixon
the fbi never explained the purpose of
that raid but dixon was working on a
documentary about joe biden hunter biden
and their business dealings in ukraine
and that's no longer allowed
a direct attack on the free press not
covered by the media
and then because this list does go on on
january 19th 2021 a journalist at
infowars called owen troyer was arrested
and charged why
well according to the federal complaint
schroer told the crowd on january 6
quote
today we march for the capital because
on this historic january 6 2021 we have
to let our congressmen and women know
and we have to let mike pence know that
they stole the election end quote now
you may not agree with that or maybe you
do it doesn't matter that's protected
speech under our constitution but under
joe biden it's a crime
and then on november 6 2021 the fbi
raided the homes of several more
journalists who worked for project
veritas including the organization's
founder james o'keefe what did they do
wrong drug trafficking human trafficking
no
they reported on a diary written by joe
biden's daughter ashley and in that
diary biden's daughter writes reveals to
the rest of us that joe biden showered
with her in a way that she described as
inappropriate and that she blames for
making her sexually compulsive in later
life
for having access to that information
the fbi rated project veritas
i'm sorry so what is this regarding
open up
oh trump's a fascist remember that
did trump's doj raid the homes of a lot
of journalists who embarrassed his
children no you don't remember that
because it didn't happen but joe biden's
justice department has done that and
then they kept going later that same
month on november 15th of last year the
justice department arrested one of the
most prominent critics that would be
former trump adviser steve bannon
now what does steve bannon do wrong did
he commit a crime on january 6 no he
didn't and no one claims otherwise
instead bannon's crime was that he
didn't bend the knee for the january 6
committee he said executive privilege
according to nancy pelosi that means
steve bannon belongs in jail
do you think people who refuse to comply
with congressional subpoenas should be
prosecuted by the justice department and
at the end of the day go to jail yes you
do i do i do well first of all this you
know people say well this hasn't
happened before we haven't had an
insurrection incited by the president of
the united states and one of his toadies
uh having knowledge of
advanced knowledge of that happening
so in fact it's important for a number
of reasons it's important for us to find
the truth
about what happened on january 6 an
assault on our constitution our congress
and our capital
an assault on the constitution okay
so no in other words we don't arrest
people for ignoring congressional
subpoenas particularly when they cite
executive privilege a principle that has
a long history in american history we've
never done that but we can do it now
because it was quote an insurrection an
insurrection that wasn't armed wasn't
planned it didn't actually insurrect
anything but it was still an
insurrection now you're beginning to see
why it's been so important from the very
first day
for the media to describe what happened
on january 6 not as a riot but as an
insurrection because if it's an
insurrection
they can violate your civil rights and
they have and they continue to a day
after steve bannon's arrest this would
be november 16 2021 the fbi raided the
home of shirona bishop that's the former
campaign manager for congresswoman
lauren beaulert of colorado according to
bishop here's what happened quote while
homeschooling my youngest children the
fbi decided was necessary to bust open
my front door with a battering ram and
put me in handcuffs so they trampled
through my home terrifying my family my
daughter was pulled around by the hoodie
by her hoodie by one of the agents
now
why would you do this to the former
chief of staff
of a sitting member of congress
well the fbi gave no reason they took
bishop's cell phone and they left
never charged with a crime then that
same day and you didn't read this in the
new york times either the feds hit the
home of mesa county republican clerk
tina peters
what was the justification for that raid
we're breaking into a lot of houses all
of a sudden of trump voters why
well in this case doj said peters raised
doubts about the legitimacy of the last
election
that's not allowed anymore can't
question the outcome
they didn't arrest her they just tore
her house apart
peter called the raid evidence of quote
a level of weaponization of the justice
department we haven't seen since the
mccarthy era but of course even during
mccarthy no one did that
in may she came on fox denver to explain
what exactly happened to her watch
my attorneys when they read the
indictment the other day they i mean uh
harvey wein steinberg and i've got the
best attorneys
and they just laughed they said are you
kidding this is this is a political
maneuver to shine the light on me to
keep me from running against and
defeating jenna griswold
oh
so in the name of punishing people for
complaining about the last election
they're subverting elections
currently taking place and last night
the woman you just saw tina peters lost
her bid for secretary of state which of
course was the whole point of targeting
her
peters would not be the last opponent of
the bide administration running for
office to be targeted by the justice
department on june 3 peter navarro who
was a trade aide to donald trump was
arrested at washington national airport
and put in leg irons and put in jail why
well days earlier he sued the january
6th committee he claimed executive
privilege in his communications with the
president again this is standard a
decades-old standard
and rather than go to court the january
6 committee simply had him arrested at
the airport and sent to jail and irons
navarro went on this show to explain
what happened to him
the mission of that
partisan witch hunt kangaroo committee
which is unduly authorized and not
properly constituted and has no subpoena
power they have only one mission to
concoct a fake hoax around january 6
based on criminal charges against trump
to prevent him from running for
reelection uh in in taking back the
white house in 2025 january that's all
this is about
so a decade ago the obama administration
was caught sending automatic weapons to
mexican drug cartels and congress wanted
to know more about this eric holder then
the attorney general had a key role in
this operation fast and furious you may
remember it so they subpoenaed him and
he ignored the subpoena and the media
applauded he was taking a noble position
but when steve bannon or peter navarro
tried to do something like that
they went to jail
again we had this exact same thing
happen in public ten years ago a federal
judge ruled that holder's privilege
claim was not legitimate
and he was still never arrested
but the rules have changed why is that
no one in corporate media ever asked
that question instead they celebrated
peter navarro's arrest a 70 year old man
at an airport
it made their day
he was indicted and when you're indicted
you're arrested what peter navarro did
it was so far out of bounds so
indefensible this prosecution is really
about punishing navarro based on his
latent disrespect for the congressional
subpoena
is weight and disrespect by the way
there's no constitutional requirement to
have respect for anybody in the u.s
government in fact in a free country
you're encouraged to disagree you are a
citizen you have that inherent right
but no more
the media think you should be sent to
jail if you show disrespect and so of
course with no media to push back
against unconstitutional overreach the
justice department kept going then on
june 9th of this year the fbi arrested a
republican candidate for governor of
michigan in fact the candidate who poll
show was in the lead his name is ryan
kelly he came on our show to explain
what happened next
there was no crime committed tucker no
never entered the capitol building
exercising my first amendment
those of us that have questions about
the
2020 election results they want to
intimidate us and they want to threaten
us not just me and my family but my
supporters as well all of us that love
america i think a lot of americans see
right through this tucker they
understand what the democrats are up to
and it's not a big deal to them they
want to know what the what the
government is going to do to actually do
the things that are affecting their
day-to-day life to bring solutions to
our state and to our country
noticing a pattern here
speak up against joe biden dare to
organize other people to speak up
against joe biden dare to run for office
against joe biden
and you raise your chances at the fbi
showing up at your house exponentially
it took months for us to recognize a
pattern in fact it took coming to brazil
where this kind of behavior is common to
realize that's exactly what's happening
in our country and as if you needed more
evidence these raids continue
on june 22nd of this month the feds
cornered former trump attorney john
eastman in a parking lot and seized his
phone they didn't even provide a warrant
before they did that watch
i'd like to see the warrant before you
take my property
all right
i want you to see
that they took my property before
providing me with the warrant
i'd like to read the word
put your hands up no warrant for you
what did that man do wrong we still
don't know
but again
is if you need more evidence that this
is a pattern that nobody is doing
anything to stop in fact some
republicans in washington are abetting
it and encouraging it there's this a day
after that was shot june 23rd
last week the fbi searched the home of
former trump doj official jeff clark
again there's no suggestion he committed
any crime of anything they did anything
wrong
what he did was say things that joe
biden and joe biden's justice department
didn't like so he was hauled out of his
home in his pajamas for maximum public
humiliation
at one point uh you know 12 agents and
two
uh fairfax county police officers uh
went into my house uh searched it for
three and a half hours they even brought
along something tucker i've never seen
before or heard of a electronic sniffing
dog
and they took all of the electronics
from my house
and
you know i don't blame the the agents i
think it you know what you're talking
about in terms of weaponization is
really about who's pointing the agents
and telling them what to do i just think
we're living in a in a era that i don't
recognize and increasingly tucker i
don't recognize the country anymore with
these kinds of stasi-like things
happening
don't blame the agents he says he's a
bigger man than we are because we do
blame the agents where the agents who
will resign their jobs before
participating in the destruction of the
us constitution we should see them any
of them is anyone else noticing this
no and no one's saying a word and
because no one is
abuses of power escalate
the show has just learned that as of
this week the dog's counter-terrorism
division is prosecuting a lawyer
involved in a dispute over election
integrity counter-terrorism
aimed at people
who ask questions about the last
election results by the way if that
doesn't pique your interest about what
exactly must have happened in the last
election nothing will why are they so
angry
every election of your lifetime has been
contested every single one there's not
an election a republican wins in which
democrats don't say yes the voting
machines were rigged no one does a thing
but suddenly that's a crime
and in this case the lawyer has not
attacked the state capital of arizona
writers just did that after roe v wade
was overturned not a single one was
arrested he didn't burn down a church
outside the white house the name of
george floyd
instead like every person we just
mentioned his crime was making joe biden
mad
according to our justice department he's
now a domestic terrorist someone needs
to stop this before it gets even crazier
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight